and
while we're on the subject of things
trump has done
we obviously have to talk
about all of the investigations against
him
because recently michael cohen donald
trump's former lawyer
fixer
came out in an interview and suggested
that there is going to be quote so much
flipping
on donald trump
once all
of these investigations get to that
point
and of course the big one recently last
week allen weisselberg trump
organization chief financial officer
pleaded guilty to 15 different counts
every count by the way that he was
charged with he pleaded guilty to
they didn't drop any of them so he had
to plead to each and every one of them
and he's only going to get five months
on rikers island he is eligible for
early release after 100 days so he's
going to spend a little over three
months in there
but the judge did warn him last week if
you do not cooperate fully truthfully
and honestly
i can put you away for 10 to 15 years on
rikers which given your age is pretty
much a life sentence
and here's the best part about
weisselberg's
cooperation
with the prosecutors
he can't plead the fifth
he cannot plead the fifth amendment
because he's already pleaded guilty to
all of the crimes he was accused of
a plea of guilty
basically does away with your fifth
amendment rights of self-incrimination
because you've already admitted you did
the things
kind of like the acceptance of a
presidential pardon if you accept a
presidential pardon our supreme court
says you can no longer plead the fifth
because acceptance of a pardon is an
acceptance of guilt
so weisselberg literally has no choice
all right you either go to rikers island
for 15 years which probably would be the
rest of his life
or you give us every single thing on
donald trump you can't get out of it you
can't excuse it you can't you know call
in sick you can't plead the fifth
you can do nothing
to stop what's coming and of course that
was just one of the examples of course
that michael cohen recently gave
because that's just one of the many
investigations that donald trump is
facing
we also have the situation in georgia
the fulton county special grand jury
and a lot of donald trump's friends
including his former lawyer rudy
giuliani
have had to testify now
and while we do not know what rudy
giuliani specifically told that special
grand jury
we do know that giuliani is out there in
the media still defending donald trump
still denying all wrongdoing
actually said recently
that he should get his law licenses back
because he hasn't incited a riot in the
last year and a half
but
rudy giuliani is kind of the same
situation
guy is 78 years old
a prison sentence for him especially
given his recent health
is likely a life sentence
even you know five years
with your health conditions
you're probably not walking out of that
jail ever again
so giuliani much like weisselberg has
the incentive
to flip on donald trump
but with rudy i think it's a different
story right i don't know that rudy would
flip
i still don't because i still think rudy
giuliani holds out a slight amount of
hope that trump's going to get back in
office
and then what make him attorney general
i guess he's going to do something great
for me i just know it i just know it he
hasn't paid the bills that i've
submitted to him but he's totally going
to take care of me eventually right
you keep on hoping rudy we'll hope right
there with you right you'll get a good
job in the second trump administration
if it ever materializes but uh
not gonna hold my breath
if you want out of this mess this mess
which by the way all of rudy giuliani's
legal troubles are because he stuck his
neck out for donald trump um if you want
out of
that you're gonna have to flip
that's your only option and that's
basically what michael cohen is telling
us
all these people whether it's with the
fake elector scheme whether it's with
the new york investigation
whether it's with the other new york
investigation whether it's with the
january 6 investigations whether it's
with the documents investigation down at
mar-a-lago
all of these horrible things that trump
has been implicated in with all of these
walls closing in
somebody somewhere somehow
is going to flip on this guy
and once that first domino falls
the rest of them as michael cohen says
gonna start flipping like crazy
what if i told you there was something
really easy you could do to speed up
your internet at home and on the go a
lot of people don't know this but it's
possible to use more than one internet
connection at the same time combining
the speed and reliability sort of like
combining your phone's mobile data with
the wi-fi from a hotel or at a coffee
shop and our sponsor speedify is what
makes it possible speedify is the only
app that can combine multiple internet
sources into one bonded super connection
to improve live streaming video calling
gaming web browsing whatever you do
online you can use it on any of your
devices pc mac iphone android linux you
can combine your home wifi with your
phone data to create a super connection
that you can use at home it runs in the
background at the click of a button it's
so easy to use you deserve faster
internet right now lose the video
buffering stop the dropped in the middle
of an important video call issues go to
speedify.com pacman the link is down
below